NARRATOR:
This is the shark tank,
where hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes
of getting an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
How about I hand out
some wine?
Absolutely. Great idea.
NARRATOR: The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll walk away
with nothing.
How much
is each light bulb?
$289.
Wow.
That sucks.
Somebody else can do it,
but we're gonna do it better.
It's a huge --
but you got to tell me how
you're gonna do it better.
No one comes in here
and says,
"You know what, Mark?
I'm gonna do it worse."
Your answers to the questions
are driving me nuts.
We're a venture capital
firm on steroids. There's
nobody like us.
NARRATOR:
If the sharks hear a great idea,
they're ready to invest
using their own money.
250k, but I need
30% of the business.
I'll make you
a lot richer faster.
NARRATOR: And they're willing
to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
I'll give you
the $350,000.
I think Robert is being
a little bit greedy.
Kevin's offer
is ridiculous.
My offer is great.
Mark is simply tagging along
on my offer.
Oh, that wasn't a real offer,
Robert, and you know it.
It's a little bit of
a feeding frenzy in the tank.
NARRATOR:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran went
from waiting tables in Manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real-estate empire.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his first internet
companies for over $350 million.
Lori Greiner, the queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents and
has launched over 300 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in retail sales.
And Mark Cuban,
notorious billionaire
entrepreneur, tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas Mavericks.
First into the tank
are entrepreneurs
with smart light bulbs
for a new generation.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Corey Egan.
And my name
is Swapnil Bora.
We're from Dallas, Texas,
and our company
is ilumi solutions.
We're here to show you
the future of lighting.
We are seeking $350,000
of investment
in exchange for 15% ownership
in our company.
Ilumi is a series
of intelligent
and tunable L.E.D. light bulbs
you control wirelessly
right from a mobile device.
It's very simple.
Screw in any number of ilumi,
download the app,
and you get complete control
over your lighting.
It's about having the right
light at the right time.
So, Barbara,
you're an early riser.
CORCORAN: Yes, I am.
Imagine waking up
feeling refreshed and alert
with a simulated sunrise that
slowly eases you out of bed.
Hmm.
Robert, got a busy day
ahead of you.
Every day.
You got your phone, your keys,
your wallet.
You head outside,
and your lights automatically
turn off behind you.
And when you return,
your lights greet you,
welcoming you home.
Kevin, connect your ilumi
to your stock portfolio
so you can know
if you're in the red...
[ laughter ]
...Or the green.
It's always red.
Lori, set the perfect romantic
candlelit atmosphere
and relax
with the husband.
CORCORAN: Ooh.
And, Mark, represent
your team and ours
by lighting it up blue and green
on game day.
Go, Mavericks. Yeah.
Yes. Go, Mavs.
And after the Mavericks win,
of course,
let the celebration begin.
[ dance music plays ]
GREINER: [ laughs ]
Whoo!
Ahh. Pretty cool.
[ music stops ]
Very cute.
Corey,
how does it work?
Do I plug something
into my outlet
and that controls
all the lights?
It is
the light themselves.
So, we have
two sizes of light,
and all you need are
the bulbs and the app.
So you just --
and you can put the bulb
into any light fixture
that you have.
any light fixture.
So, we've got --
so, you're using Wi-Fi
in a house then?
It's actually
bluetooth-based.
Bluetooth.
So, where are you at with this
in the market?
So, we're at the final stages
of development.
Swapnil and I were
actually classmates
at U.T. Dallas
where we came up with the idea.
We're now right at the doorstep
to manufacturing,
which is why, really,
we're here today.
How much
is each light bulb?
$289 for a three-pack.
Whoa.
CORCORAN: Wow.
It's $90 a light bulb.
Correct.
Wow.
How long does it last compared
to a normal light bulb?
It lasts
up to 20 years.
From the consumer point
of view,
making that decision
between a $100 bulb
and one for $2.80
is gonna be a very tough call.
What we've seen is
that both consumers
as well as commercial folks
when they're looking to get
the most from their space,
ilumi is actually
an easier and more
cost-effective solution.
You're not selling
light bulbs.
You're selling
a lighting system.
Exactly.
Correct.
So tell me how many steps it
takes to get the system working.
It takes
essentially two steps.
Screw in the light bulb.
Got it.
Download the app. Go straight
to the setup process.
From that, the bulb finds
the app...
Can I see the app?
Sure.
...Connects,
and that's it.
I have to ask
the magic question.
Do you have a patent pending
on this or a patent on this?
Great question.
We have filed U.S.
And one international
utility patents pending.
O'LEARY:
Tell me if I'm wrong,
but I'm sort of focusing
on what matters in this deal.
If your I.P. clears,
if your intellectual property
clears,
you don't really want to be
in the light bulb-building
business
and distribution
and logistics business.
Or do you?
This is our answer.
So, we know that the value
in this company
will come from, one,
building a great company
that we are manufacturing
and shipping bulbs.
Wow.
There's so many players
in the light business
that have
massive market share.
If I -- if there was ever
a licensing deal
in the shark tank, you're it.
But you're telling me,
"I can't wait to build
my light-bulb factory."
That sucks.
CUBAN: When are you gonna have
your samples,
and when will you
be able to ship?
So, our goal is to ship
by the end of this year.
So we're ready to start
the tooling process right now.
That's one of the reasons
we're here
and we're asking
for the $350,000.
Your money gets our product
into customers' hands.
I just want to clear
the field.
Sure.
I'm -- I hate to tell you,
I'm a disbeliever here.
Turning on my lights
with my iPad
for me just seems weird.
And $99 for a light bulb
versus 3 bucks
is a heck of a hard sell.
Sure.
It just doesn't strike me
as a realistic amount.
Well, I appreciate
your consideration, Barbara.
Pleasure.
I'm concerned with some
of your competition out there
because I know
you do have competition.
And I'm not sure --
I think I love this
for the consumer market.
But I'm not sure
where you're gonna fall
when you finish everything
if you get the I.p.
If you don't, then I'm afraid
that you're not going to be able
to be competitive.
So, for that reason, I'm out.
Where I see
a real opportunity
is in the lighting market
that is very complicated
and very high-end.
Yes.
In that market,
your $100 light bulb is cheap.
Exactly. Exactly.
Exactly.
HERJAVEC: Okay.
All right.
Let me start with an offer.
I'll give you
the $350,000
for 35%.
Well, first of all, I really
appreciate the offer, Robert.
So, you know, thank you,
and I'm excited that you're
interested in ilumi.
I would like to,
if it's okay,
be open to other offers,
as well.
All right, guys.
I'll make it easy. Look.
I think Robert is being
a little bit greedy,
but I'm not gonna be
totally ungreedy
because I think I can bring
a lot of value.
So, what I'll offer you
is the $350,000 for 25%.
Mark, we really appreciate
your offer, as well.
Wow, wow, wow, wow.
Ichi-wow-a.
HERJAVEC: I know!
Oh, my God.
You got to tell me
yes or no.
If it --
if it's too much equity
and that's what you feel,
and you have a --
you have a limit
that you've set for yourselves,
then let's not go
back and forth.
sure --
just tell me the limit and if
you want to do a deal with me,
then we'll figure it out.
Well, why don't you wait and see
if you have any other offers?
EGAN: I-I would
appreciate that.
If possible,
I'd also like to see
if there's other folks
with more questions.
You know, Corey,
I wouldn't --
All right, guys.
I'm out.
NARRATOR: Corey and Swapnil
had two offers on the table,
but their indecision
has changed Mark's mind.
If it's too much equity
and that's what you feel,
and you have a --
you have a limit
that you've set for yourselves,
then let's not go
back and forth.
sure --
just tell me the limit and if
you want to do a deal with me,
then we'll figure it out.
Well, why don't you wait and see
if you have any other offers?
I-I would
appreciate that.
If possible,
I'd also like to see
if there's other folks
with more questions.
You know, Corey,
I wouldn't --
all right, guys.
I'm out.
Doggone it. I was gonna warn you
on that one.
EGAN: Mark, I --
you know, I-I know the
24-second shot clock.
I didn't even get
the 24-second shot clock.
CUBAN: Yeah, it's not even
about that, guys. Look.
It was an opportunity to say,
"Look, Mark. Here's the number."
Yeah.
and if you wanted to do
business with me,
you would have given me
the number.
Mark, if you could give us
a moment,
we would love to take
the time.
fine, that's fine.
that's fine.
Is that all right?
Okay. Fine, fine, fine.
Okay. All right. Thank you.
O'LEARY: I'll -- I'll put
another offer on the table
that doesn't involve
so much equity.
My offer's much simpler.
I'm not interested
in any equity at all.
I'll give you $350,000
upon the clearance
of your I.p.
And one contingency --
that you allow me to license it
to a very large
light-bulb manufacturer.
I'm not interested
in funding
growth in manufacturing
light bulbs.
I want 15%
of the royalty stream.
You keep the whole company.
I'll make you a lot richer
faster with my strategy.
And if you can't get
a license, what then?
It reverts back to them.
So, Corey, let's
just keep in mind
the person who first made you
the offer...
Yes.
...Was me.
Mark is simply tagging along
on my offer.
Yeah.
Kevin's royalty deal
is just ludicrous.
You can't do that.
You need both of those options.
Right.
I don't know.
You should think about that.
My offers are
always very well thought-out.
Guys, you -- you already know
what's going on here, right?
Robert didn't quite get
it, so he asked for a
chunk of the company.
Kevin did
what he always does...
That's ridiculous.
I got it right away.
...And put out
a ridiculous offer.
Why do you want
to manufacture anything?
Why do you want to go
through that headache?
Look, if someone comes along
and makes the right offer
on a licensing deal,
yeah, absolutely, right?
But the biggest upside
for this company
is going to come
from ongoing development.
You know,
that's ridiculous.
You could get a $4 million
advance on your license,
fund your next five ideas
from it,
and never spend an hour
in the plant.
You guys are nuts.
EGAN:
I think the challenge
that I'm seeing is,
you know, we do --
the patents are pending,
and, you know, we've put
a lot in to that.
It's getting
from here to there.
Are your patents gonna clear
or not? What do you think?
Even if they don't --
oh, I'm sorry, my friend.
If they don't, you've got
a world of hurt.
You're just off to --
no, 'cause you're just
off to the races,
and it's a real business --
just a nice small
light-bulb manufacturer.
Look,
in my perfect world,
all the patents for software
go away anyways,
and you just hustle
and you grind.
this is not software.
It's a little bit of
a feeding frenzy in the tank.
EGAN: Yes.
HERJAVEC: Corey, look.
You know what?
I'm out.
And I'll tell you why I wanted
so much equity.
It was simply commensurate
with the risk.
I don't see
that wide a market.
So I think you've got one
equity offer, and you've
got and a royalty offer.
So, guys, he's out.
EGAN: Yeah.
Kevin's offer
is ridiculous.
My offer's great. I just want
you to deliver the patent.
Kevin, I'm gonna get him
to write a software program
that just puts a puppet there
and just recalculates
the same offer
and just the same offer.
because I'm right
every time,
over and over and over.
enough! enough, guys.
Corey,
if you go with Mark,
you're gonna listen
to this every day.
EGAN: So, first of all,
I want to thank you all
for your time today again.
Kevin, we appreciate the offer,
but it doesn't really match
with the vision for what
we're trying to achieve.
You want
to make light bulbs.
We want to make
light bulbs
and make a great business
and bring ilumi to the world.
Mark, would you be willing
to meet in the middle
at 20% for the $350,000?
I'm gonna stick
to the 25%, guys,
'cause you know I can bring
a huge amount of value.
Could I ask you --
I think everyone in here
could pick up the phone
and make one phone call
that could change the game
for us.
Who would be
your phone call?
Depends on who we need
to call.
All right? There's nobody
that's not gonna take my call.
Good answer.
That's a good answer.
Okay, Mark.
You've got a deal.
I knew it.
Let's go to work.
GREINER: Good deal.
Congratulations.
It's a great program, guys.
Thank you.
Congratulations, man.
I'm looking forward
to it. Yes, sir.
Thanks, Mark.
That's what
I'm talking about.
Live your lights.
Light up your life, baby.
Mark, I want one.
EGAN: Working with Mark,
it's gonna be a tremendous fit.
He gets the technology
that we're bringing
and our vision
to make it happen.
Mark's just gonna be
like fuel on the fire.
It's -- this thing is gonna
spread like wildfire,
and ilumi's gonna shine
across the world.
NARRATOR:
Earlier this season,
Charles yim made a deal
with all five sharks
for his smartphone breathalyzer,
Breathometer.
All five sharks will give you
$1 million for 30%.
I accept.
All right.
GREINER: Whoo!
NARRATOR: Let's see
what's happening now.
Since "Shark Tank,"
it's been crazy busy.
We've got a ton
of pre-orders --
actually more than we can
even catch up with.
When I first went in the tank,
we only had $140,000 in sales.
After closing a deal
with all five sharks,
we closed $1 million
in just three months.
We had to scale up
our production
just to keep up
with the demand.
Charles.
Hey, Kevin.
O'LEARY: I came to the bay area
today to check in on Charles.
It's unique
that we have a deal
where every shark has put
their money to work.
Everybody knows this thing is
going to be very successful.
I'm their eyes today.
I'm getting
a lot of e-mails
from people that do not have
their device yet.
Right.
What are you doing
about it?
Being back-ordered is
not a good problem.
You want happy customers,
not ones that are waiting
for their product.
I have to come here
and beat him with a stick.
We were only manufacturing
roughly about 1,000 units
a week.
Now we're at 15,000 units
We'll be, in about three
weeks, current with
all our pre-orders.
And then the backlog
will be filled.
Yep.
The operation looks
like it's working.
He's been delayed.
Now he's getting the product
out the door.
This is important.
Hey, guys.
Look who stopped by.
YIM: Working with all five
sharks has been amazing.
Each brings value to the table
in a very different, unique way.
Kevin's been helping us
with international distribution.
Mark's been instrumental
in bringing us
to big-box retailers.
Lori's working on helping us
get on QVC.
Robert and Daymond
have helped us with
distribution here in the U.S.,
but on top of that,
they've really helped
us refine our branding.
JOHN: You know, not only
are you saving lives,
I know you want to make it
more of a science technology
and medical company.
We're now more than just
a smartphone breathalyzer.
We're moving on to things
like halitosis,
dehydration, diabetes,
asthma.
Our main goal is
to improve patient healthcare
and continue saving lives.
So to be able to see the company
launch a product
and create new jobs
in just three months,
it's an amazing feeling
to have.
My name
is Felix Brandon Lloyd,
and this is my wife,
Jordan Lloyd Bookey.
We live in Washington, D.C.,
with our two beautiful kids,
and we're the founders
of Zoobean.
Whee!
[ laughs ]
My son received
a book in the mail
from a family friend.
And he so loved this book,
both because it was
a wonderful story
and it pictured
a mixed family like ours.
Everybody's going
in the water.
JORDAN: He read it every day
that week.
And it was a very powerful
experience for us.
And it dawned on us
that we could create
this delightful experience
for families everywhere.
That's why
we created Zoobean.
Felix and I have both been
in education for many years.
For us, education is
really everything.
It is the one thing
that if we get it right,
it can help change the
trajectory of anybody's life.
Zoobean means to us
an opportunity to make
a difference in the world
and make a difference
in our own lives
and our children's lives.
[ laughter ]
Hi.
My name's Jordan.
But when it comes
to business,
you can call me
the chief mom.
And I'm Felix --
of course, the chief dad.
Our company
is called Zoobean,
and we're seeking
a $250,000 investment
in exchange
for 15% equity.
We first met
as teachers.
But it's
when we became parents
that building
our kids' love of reading
became more personal.
The truth is,
we found it difficult
to discover children's books
that met our kids'
particular interests
or that pictured families
like ours.
And that's
why we created Zoobean,
a children's book
discovery platform
and highly personalized
subscription service.
So, Zoobean uses filters
like recommended age,
language,
interests like
not-so-pink girls,
or main character's
background,
like being
from a mixed family.
That way, our platform
curates the right book
and eventually
other products.
For us, Zoobean is
as much our mission
as it is our business.
Sharks, please join us
in helping
all of our kids imagine
and achieve anything.
So, you're pre-selecting
for them,
making the task easier.
I-I lived in this space
for 12 years,
and I'm gonna guess
that 80% of your sales
are between the ages of 3 and 8
years old, okay?
So, here's the problem --
in actually acquiring
the customer at that age,
for every company that's tried,
has been a huge challenge
in actually the cost
of customer acquisition
because you've got
about 20 million people
moving through that zone
every 12 months.
This is the whole business,
my friends.
That's all there is
to worry about.
Do you know what your
customer-acquisition cost is?
Customer-acquisitions cost
is about $6.03.
Wow.
How many have you
been able to get?
How many subscribers
do you have?
We have 85 subscribers
and gifters.
HERJAVEC: 85,000?
85 subscribers
and gifters.
We launched a beta version
just two months ago.
It seems to me there's a need
for what you're doing.
I don't know, though. Is there
other competition out there?
Yeah, Amazon.
[ chuckles ]
Is this something
that people are really needing
and you're fulfilling that
in the marketplace?
I think I can start
to answer
by -- by finishing
how the product works.
As a user, you can come
to the site
and state a number
of preferences.
Once all that data's
in there,
automatically our system
will then query and say,
"Mr. Cuban's child has
a reading level this level,
is interested in this type
of subject, these --"
Okay, so, that's
still very simple search
based off of tags, right,
which isn't going
to get you very far
because you can put together
lists on Amazon,
and you can even put together
subscriptions on Amazon.
What I'm trying to do is figure
out if there is a secret sauce.
Yes. Right.
Right.
What's the secret sauce?
It's the difference
between Google
and another search engine,
right?
What is it
that makes you different?
Technology-wise,
when you look at it,
the back end is data
and -- and -- and
matching tags with data.
Firstly, we assign a relevant
score to each of those users.
Okay.
And that relevant score
is based
on those tags
being weighted.
And then it becomes informed
by user behavior.
And then we say
these are the potential items
that could match up
with this.
So, the difference
between you and Amazon
is you're more specific.
But I think, though,
there's nothing really
that unique.
And so, for that reason,
I'm out.
I'm sorry to hear that.
Thank you.
CORCORAN:
Help me with an example.
I have a 7-year-old daughter
who's adopted.
And when she was born,
I went on Amazon.
So here's a perfect parallel.
A specialty --
I wanted to find
every book on adoption
and storybooks for children.
Yes.
What would have been
different
if I had gone on your website
and had that same experience?
If you'd gone on our website,
first of all,
it would have been probably
a more pleasant experience.
You'd go through, you'd -- you'd
look, and you'd see adoption.
Then you might want,
you know,
female characters,
for example, for your --
in other words, if I had
something very specific.
Now I want it just about little
girls who are adopted.
I could put
female adoption?
Right.
Correct. Correct.
That have
female characters --
so -- so to Lori's point --
I-I think
she was clear on that.
I really don't think there's
a need for the business,
so I am out.
Jordan, tell us
a little about your background.
Jordan just left her job
as head of k--
a week ago.
A week -- a week ago
as head of k-through-12
education at Google.
GREINER: Oh, wow.
Wow.
CORCORAN: To focus
on this full-time?
Yes.
HERJAVEC: Felix,
what's your background?
I'm Washington --
I'm a former Washington,
D.C., teacher of the year.
And then after that, I left
and started a technology venture
that I had an exit from
three years ago.
It was kids-
and education-related.
I think you guys
are very solid
'cause my children
are voracious readers.
Yes.
JORDAN: Yes.
HERJAVEC:
But I got to tell you,
they can go online,
and they can search
for almost any book that they
want to find today.
And I just currently don't see
it today. I'm out.
Thank you.
Finding the customer
and getting the full value,
which is really
only about five years,
I don't know if you're gonna get
there with this baby.
I'm not kidding. It's --
it's a -- it's gonna be
a really tough, uh, ride.
But isn't that
what it's about?
Isn't business about a struggle?
I mean, Jeff Bezos --
I get it.
I get all that.
But I just -- I-I'm trying
to find a way to get excited
because this is my space --
or was my space.
Well, get excited
about changing the world.
No, I --
you know,
one of these things that --
listen to me, seriously.
I don't want to change
the world.
I want to make money.
He doesn't get excited
about that, Felix.
I know that. M-making money
changes the world.
You come into the shark tank,
you get all of these sharks
that have had experience
in different sectors.
mm-hmm.
And it -- we're a venture
capital firm on steroids.
There's nobody like us.
You're all hearing
the different challenges
from -- from all of us,
and -- and the one --
the only one I care about is
the one that I've lived through,
which is
customer-acquisition cost.
I think you'll do a great job
monetizing it
after you've got them.
But I think
they're gonna cost you
more than you'll make
off of them.
And for that reason, I'm out.
Is everybody else out?
Yeah.
Good.
Guys, I-I disagree
completely.
I think trusted curation
is the future.
The question is,
what's after books?
Because the value in
this has nothing to do
with books, right?
It has everything to do
with helping grandma
find something
when she has no idea
what to get.
Absolutely.
But you haven't convinced me
that you've got something,
or -- and you haven't told me
why you've got something
that allows that to happen
in a way that someone else
can't do.
Now, somebody else can do it,
but we're gonna do it better.
It's a huge --
but you got to tell me how
you're gonna do it better.
No one says --
no one comes in here and says,
"You know what, Mark?
I'm gonna do it worse,"
or, "I'm just gonna
do it average,"
or, "I'm gonna do it
the same as everybody else."
You haven't explained to me.
Because, Mark, you see --
you see an awful lot
of technology plays.
This is not
a technology company.
But that's what I'm trying
to figure out, 'cause --
it's not.
it's a marketing company.
Let me decide
if it's technology or not, okay?
Yeah, but they're not even
telling you they're playing
it on a technology platform.
That's like saying Google is
just a search company, right?
Right.
It's -- it's just not,
right?
Right.
Because I'm trying to figure out
where this can go.
Yes, thank you.
Right? What --
what is it capable of doing?
Right.
Could the software
be extended
so that if you created
an inventory
of all the children's-oriented
shows on Netflix...
Yes.
Mm-hmm. Yeah.
...All the movies
on Netflix...
...And a current
programing guide...
Yes.
...From all the different
TV networks...
Yes.
...Could I go in there
and it would tell me
which shows are appropriate
and recommend which?
Yes.
Exactly what it could do.
Yes, exactly.
CUBAN: So now if, all
of a sudden, you're
saying, Zoobean,
you're not quite sure what shows
your kids can watch, right?
Mm-hmm.
Right.
Put in this data,
we'll show you
which shows are applicable,
whether it's Netflix...
Yes.
...Whether it's Hulu,
whether it's anywhere.
And, oh, by the way,
buy our books.
Now you're getting
two different ways to populate.
Yes.
But that's happening
already.
Oh, my goodness.
No, not -- not within
one centralized location.
Yeah? Check out Disney.
No, not -- not --
no, I'm not talking about
TV guides and everything.
I'm -- out-outside of Disney,
you want someplace,
'cause not all Disney's gonna be
appropriate for what you do.
right.
It's got to be
independent. Okay.
Right.
So, guys, if that's the case,
I'll make you an offer.
FELIX: All right.
250k, but I need
30% of the business.
Would you consider 20%?
I'll meet you
in the middle.
Mark, we are excited and
ecstatic to accept your offer.
Let's do this.
Thank you.
Hey, you're -- you're nice guys.
We'll do a deal.
Poker face not -- not
as good as you.
Thank you, Mark.
My pleasure.
Great deal. Good luck.
Thanks. Thank you.
[ laughter ]
It's the same thing
about Netflix.
Netflix at the beginning
and the recommendation engine
started with nothing.
This has
to go through that.
But, Mark, Netflix had
a unique proposition
out of the gate.
no, they didn't.
Sure, they did.
No, they didn't.
Netflix's big angle was
data, and they put cash
up front to get content.
Look. This is
a very binary business.
It's either a home run, or --
or it's a strikeout, right?
And if they hit it,
it's enormous.
NARRATOR: Next up are
father-and-son entrepreneurs
with a unique
food-preservation system.
Hi.
My name is Chase Hoyt.
And this is my father.
I'm Bob Hoyt.
We're from Tucson, Arizona,
and our company is
Intelli-Stopper Technology.
We're seeking $250,000
in exchange
for 10% equity.
Sharks,
our Intelli-Stopper Technology
will redefine
and revolutionize
food and beverage
preservation.
The problem
with current wine preservers is
you never know when
you've pumped out the
right amount of air,
and you never know when air gets
back into the bottle.
And preservers on the market
allow air
to seep back in within minutes
to hours of preserving.
So, Mr. Wonderful,
that very expensive bottle
of '69 Château Margaux
that you have is being --
just one of many.
just one --
is being exposed to oxygen
when you think
it's being preserved...
Until now.
The intelli-stopper is
the first preserver
on the market that has
a red visual indicator.
So for the first time,
you can see that all
of your wine is preserved.
Let me show you
how it works.
But before I do,
how about I hand out some wine?
Absolutely. Great idea.
Sure.
Here we go.
Thank you.
There you go.
Lori.
It's better than boxed.
Ladies first.
Thank you.
There we go.
Absolutely.
There you go.
Cheers.
Mr. Wonderful.
Thank you.
Absolutely.
CORCORAN: It's free.
It might not be as good
as O'Leary fine wines,
but it's pretty darn good.
Of course. Thank you.
I'm sure
it's much better.
There we go.
So, drink up, you guys.
Thank you.
If I -- if I have a sip of this
and I go blind,
there'll be hell to pay.
It's great wine.
Okay, that wine has
been preserved with
the intelli-stopper.
How long was it
since it was opened?
Five days.
Okay.
Well -- well, show us
how it works, Chase.
Sure. Absolutely.
We've had a few glasses
of wine.
Put the stopper in the top
of the bottle.
You can see that red indicator
is up right now
because, obviously, there's
still oxygen in there.
Pump the air out,
and you'll see
that red indicator goes down.
When you see a clear window,
you know that your wine
is preserved.
So, by taking the air
out of it...
Yes.
...It -- the wine
lasts longer.
Absolutely.
Yeah, so --
so if I don't do
the preserver thing...
Yeah.
...How long will
the wine last?
So, on average, um, maybe
two days, maybe three days.
That's it?
And that bottle of wine,
how long will that last?
With this product, it will
last up to two weeks.
If air gets back
in that bottle,
you're gonna see the red
indicator creeps right back up.
O'LEARY:
Yeah, but, Chase --
so you can visually see that
your wine is preserved.
I have, I don't know,
six cellars now...
Sure.
...With tens of thousands
of bottles of wine.
I own every single preservation
system ever made...
Yeah.
...Including the ones
that do nitrogen, argon gas,
you name it.
Right.
Yours is a derivative
of a very popular one
that does do $15 million
in sales.
You've added an indicator
that air goes in.
That's the only difference,
right?
Yes.
Is this
the only product?
We have four skus
with this product line.
Okay.
And we are extending
into multiple markets.
Chase,
what were your sales?
Last year,
we sold $150,000.
This year, we're on pace
to sell $300,000.
And we just locked
a major retailer,
which is really exciting.
Which one?
Bed Bath & Beyond.
Really?
People that are passionate
about wine buy everything.
I'll buy one, but for me
to get my head
around a value
of $2 1/2 million...
As a start-up company,
you should never argue value.
Instead, we have to show you
a-a limited perception of risk,
and that's exactly
what we've done...
Oh, well said.
...Because what we have --
proof of concept,
we have growing sales,
we've got proof of market,
we've got patented
intellectual property.
All right, so what's next?
Okay, so what's next?
So, we're taking all of this
technology to --
the first is olive-oil
preservation with olivedoctor.
Think about the olive oil
that you have
that sits on your counter
or in your cupboard
that goes
stale and rancid.
You use it for --
olive oil goes stale?
Absolutely. Actually --
I thought
it lasts forever.
Or is it honey
that lasts forever?
Honey -- honey does
last forever.
Does love last forever?
O'LEARY: I know -- you know,
Robert, I know there's --
there's somewhere on you
I could plug this in
and suck the air out of you.
[ laughter ]
But once you get up
to about a month,
depending on the olive oil,
it's rancid.
Sealed?
There's one challenge
with the high-end olive oils
is that the bottle sizes
vary dramatically.
I have a pretty large collection
of olive oils,
and this would only work
in maybe 10% of the bottles.
Really expensive oils are being
collected like wines now.
It's in my wine cellar.
You collect oils?
[ laughs ]
So when you open it up...
But it's not black oil.
...You may have one or two
months to use it.
I've got some oils
that are $300 a bottle.
Do you really?
You got what?!
Yeah.
What are your other applications
for this?
The next, which we're very
excited about, is to coffee.
So, 2.4 billion cups of coffee
are consumed every day.
We can take our intelli-stopper
technology --
Okay.
We know there's a big market.
Do you have the patent
for any of this?
Well, we have
three patents.
We have two design patents --
one in the U.S., the other is
in the European union --
and we have pending
a functionality patent,
and so we have
some protection on that.
When you say functionality,
you mean utility patent?
Utility.
Yeah.
I feel like everybody
has seen dozens
of these kinds of things
claiming to preserve wine
in particular.
And I, for one, have bought
many of them.
Yeah.
I don't think there's
enough point of difference
that makes this jump apart
from the crowd and me say,
"Wow! I got to get
my hands on this thing."
So, because it seems
like more of the same
with a little twist,
I'm out.
Okay.
Guys, it's obvious that you've
built a better mousetrap.
But I have no idea what
the mouse is and where it goes.
People collect oils?
Seriously?
I thought those things
get better with age.
So, I mean, it's really not
a fit for me.
So, for those reasons,
I'm out.
GREINER: For me, the problem
here is, is I've seen a lot --
I'm very familiar
with this space.
And there are other products
out there very similar,
so I'm out.
Chase, let me make it
really simple.
Not for me.
I'm out.
So, I use your competitor
every day
because I start my evening with
a single glass of Montrachet
which often comes out
of a new bottle.
And your breakfast
and your lunch.
[ laughter ]
And then I -- then I stop it
and put it back into the cooler
with the competing product.
CHASE: Right.
And then I hit the reds.
Mm-hmm.
So, I generally have
two bottles stopped.
The reason they have my business
is they have the distribution.
I think the problem with this
deal is the value put on it.
There's so much we could be
doing together
if you weren't
such greedy pigs.
[ chuckles ]
That's really
the problem here.
You've -- you've --
it's impossible
to give you $250,000 for --
I'd have to own
the whole company.
I'm sorry, but I'm out.
Okay.
CUBAN: Good luck, guys.
Thank you, Bob.
Thanks, Chase.
Thanks, guys.
Thank you.
GREINER: Good luck, guys.
All the best.
Thank you.
Kevin,
we're all friends here.
Yes.
We love you.
You have a problem.
[ laughter ]
NARRATOR:
Next up is a product
designed to unleash a child's
creativity and imagination.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Erika Pope,
and my company is Fort Magic.
I am here seeking
a $75,000 investment
in exchange for 15%
of my company.
Remember being a kid and how
much fun it was to build forts
when you wanted to bring your
greatest fantasies to life,
but the frustration you had
that all you had to work with
was couch cushions
that would fall apart
or a card table that looked
nothing like your imagination?
Well, enter Fort Magic,
where a child can build a fort
as big as their imagination.
The magic of our Fort Magic kit
is in the large number
and variety
of sticks and connectors
included in every kit.
With just one Fort Magic kit,
a child can build
unlimited fort designs.
They can build a castle fort.
They could build a pirate ship.
Or they could build a racecar.
Who's ready to come aboard
a company that has a product
that has been repeatedly called
the best money spent
on a toy ever?
Erika, you must have
very amazing numbers.
Yes, it has been
amazingly received.
You want to share those
with us?
Sure. So, Fort Magic has been
open for 18 months.
And in those 18 months,
we have made $150,000 in sales.
O'LEARY:
Erika, how have you sold it?
You've done it online?
Have you worked with retailers?
We sell almost entirely through
Amazon, as a matter of fact.
HERJAVEC: Erika, tell me
a little bit about the product.
You mention one kit
can do multiple things.
Did I understand
that correctly?
That is correct.
How big is that kit?
So, each kit comes
with all of these pieces.
There are 384 pieces
in a kit.
When you receive
the retail box,
it's 26 inches by 10 inches
by 10 inches.
Oh, wow. That's big.
Yes, but every
Fort Magic kit comes
with a very high quality,
excellent storage bag.
That's gonna be difficult
to get into retail ever.
That's a very large footprint.
What's the unique part
of the connectors?
Have you -- is -- is the way
that they connect unique?
Like, when I put it together,
is it -- is it hard?
Like, how do I --
oh, I have test samples.
Would you like to try some?
Yes.
Sure.
Here, everyone.
Here's some pieces.
HERJAVEC: It's actually
really well made.
Like, it's a lot sturdier
than I would have thought.
It's very sturdy.
This can't be patentable,
is it?
POPE: Actually,
we are patent-pending.
O'LEARY: So, tell me
about the numbers.
Tell us what it costs,
what it costs to make,
who's making it for you.
Sure.
Is it built in America
or offshore?
Okay.
What are your margins,
all that good stuff?
That's a lot of questions
at once. Oh, my gosh.
It's all one question.
No problem. I'll answer
all of them, no problem.
Well, because I want
to know about money.
Sure, of course.
We all want to know about money
when it comes to business,
so no problem.
I just want to bring
to your attention, by the way,
this is our teepee,
and simultaneous to the teepee,
you can make
your stick buddy horse.
So, just pointing that
out to you.
[ laughs ]
What's your background?
How did you come up with this?
I was a stay-at-home mom
for 15 years,
and I love being
a stay-at-home mom,
and I, you know, love
my children.
My son was playing
with his dryer box
that was falling apart.
I just thought, "You know,
we can do better than this."
And then we started playing
with the idea.
And we actually --
we had to invent the
way to bend our sticks.
When I started playing with it,
it was so much fun.
And then when we covered it,
it was,
"Oh, it's so adorable.
It's so cute."
Back to the numbers.
back to the numbers.
Well, but the thing is,
before the numbers...
O'LEARY: Okay, please.
Let me ask you --
wait, wait, wait.
Before I die of old age,
tell me what these sell for
and how much you make.
let me ask you
one thing, though.
None of the fabric
comes with, though.
That you have to do
yourself.
That is correct.
Which fabric?
All the fabrics on these.
Any of the fabric.
Does it come with a mom
to make the fabrics
to cover the shell?
So, tell me
about the numbers.
Um, our -- not deviating
from the numbers on purpose.
I think you are.
Okay, great. So, our Fort Magic
kit sells for $199.
Whoa. Ain't cheap.
We currently manufacture the
Fort Magic kit for $40 a kit.
And we can get it
to the end user for $50 a kit.
So our margins are 75%.
We profit approximately,
well, $100 per kit.
How much money have you put
into this?
So, I have invested $50,000.
Um, my mother has invested
$200,000.
Ohh!
$200,000?!
Yes, $200,000.
Whoa, mommy dearest.
How much does mommy own
of the company?
So, the original split
is 50/50,
but we recently brought in
another investor.
He's actually committed
$200,000 at 35%.
What does that do
to the equity breakdown?
'cause he's gonna get 35%,
you and your mom
were 50/50.
Yes.
Right?
Who takes the hit?
Is it just equally,
so now you're all...
Equally.
...Basically third, third,
third partners.
Well, essentially, yes.
But I have complete authority
to negotiate here today.
Erika, let me say, I think
your enthusiasm is delicious.
Thank you.
You're bubbling over,
but let me tell you,
your answers to the questions
are driving me nuts.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Yeah.
You're all over the place.
I feel like you don't know
what you're shooting at.
Let me give you one shot
at that.
Okay, yes.
If I said to you, what are
your top three priorities,
starting tomorrow morning
when you go to work,
what would they be?
Um...Sorry,
I'm quite caught off guard.
Top three priorities.
Well, immediately
or in general? I'm sorry.
Immediate --
the next day,
the next week.
You're making her point.
You realize that.
[ chuckles ]
Well, I'm sorry.
Okay, I've never seen
an entrepreneur
ever in my life succeed
without being
hyper-focused
on exactly
what's most important.
For me, it certainly
wouldn't be a good fit,
and I'm sad to say
I'm out.
Well, I-I don't know
what to say
except other than I definitely
believe in Fort Magic.
Erika, you're going
200 miles an hour,
and I don't know what direction
you're going in.
I don't think you know what
direction you're going in.
I don't think
you're focused enough.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
Well, thank you.
Erika, most families
in America
can't pay $199
for a child's toy.
They just can't.
I mean, that is really high
in the children's toy business.
If you want this to be big,
it has to be for under $100.
I'm out.
Okay. Thanks, Kevin.
Okay. Robert and Lori?
[ chuckles ]
I agree with Kevin.
I think that it's expensive
for what it is
and that you don't get
everything to put it together.
If it came at $199
with all of the fabric
and everything
that you have in front of us,
then that would be, to me,
a great price.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
Thanks, Lori.
HERJAVEC: You know,
one of the things
I've learned on "Shark Tank"
after five seasons
is there are some products
that when people come on,
the audience
is gonna buy in droves.
I think you're gonna sell
a ton of forts.
Are you making
an offer?
NARRATOR:
Four sharks are out.
Erika only has one chance
to make a deal.
I think you're gonna sell
a ton of forts.
O'LEARY: Are you making
an offer?
I am making an offer.
My challenge
is keeping you focused.
For me to be involved
with the business,
I would need to be
an equal partner with you.
$75,000 for 50%.
Okay, thank you, Robert.
Let me ask you this,
Robert.
For 50%, can you tell me
exactly what you think
that you'll be bringing
in terms of, like, moving
our distribution
and moving our sales for us
this year and in the future?
That's the smartest question
you've asked so far.
No, Erika,
that is a great question.
There's a bunch of things
that I think
my team and I
can help you focus on.
You got to sell the materials
with it and stuff like that.
Which will add cost.
So I think you could --
it will add cost, but I think
that's an option for people.
I would take it
to retail,
but I'd have
to see the packaging.
I just keep going back to,
I think you're gonna sell
a lot of forts.
50% is too much, unfortunately.
It's too much.
And I understand that, um --
O'LEARY: What would you sell
for $75,000,
given that he's made you
an offer, and that's
an achievement here?
Many people come on
"Shark Tank" with toys.
Very few get offers.
He's reflecting
the challenges ahead
in his risk profile
of your business,
and he wants to be paid
for the risk.
And you haven't done a really
good job in de-risking it,
because, as Barbara said,
you're scatterbrained,
you know?
No, no.
No.
CORCORAN: I didn't say
exactly that.
Okay. Mr. Wonderful,
I am not scatterbrained.
Hey, I'm just --
that's right.
You tell him.
I may be enthusiastic,
but I am actually very driven
and very hard-working,
and I have brought us this far.
Okay, then get focused
on the offer.
I don't know that
you're gonna like it, Robert,
but honestly, I was thinking
more something like 25%.
I'm not gonna change
from that.
I really appreciate it,
but I'm gonna have to say no.
CORCORAN: Good for you.
CUBAN: Good for you.
GREINER: Good for you,
and you'll make it.
Yeah.
Everybody's clapping.
They didn't make you an offer.
Oh, that wasn't a real offer,
Robert, and you know it.
Okay, how --
you -- you did not expect her
to take it, and you know it.
How do I deal with all
the other partners, Mark?
How do I deal
with the other partners?
You did not -- you did not
expect her to take it.
Just because she spent
$250,000 in the past
doesn't change
where we are right now today.
I'm just telling you it wasn't
a real offer, Robert.
All right.
Thank you, everyone.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
Good luck
with everything.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
Ha to you, Robert.
Look, Barbara,
I had the ability
to make an offer
that works for me.
O'LEARY: That business
is so screwed up.
You can't sell
a lot of these at $200.
Sure, you can.
That's ridiculous.
I don't think so.
For 200 bucks, that car should
have an engine in it.
[ chuckles ]
POPE: I'm actually
a very focused person.
Even though I may not answer
every question immediately,
that certainly doesn't take
anything away from the fact
that I know exactly what we're
doing with Fort Magic.
I know what our plan is. I know
where we are going forward.
And I'm just really excited
about the future
for our company.